i'm not bullish on california and that
ain't me i've talked to some very smart
people who are economic
animals and all of them agree and all of
them are looking to get out
because it's too expensive why why i
live
in on skid row basically i'm in venice
i've been in venice for 25 years i love
it
but i don't recognize my town anymore as
much
and you know it's gotten really bad over
there it's not just gotten very bad it's
become profitable
because developers now can get these
government contracts i mean
i can build you i can build you a bunch
of apartments for 200 million dollars on
prime real estate
on a parking lot in on the beach if
you'd like i'd be happy to do that and
we can just have we can create a
homeless
apartments people for for people who are
homeless and uh
don't worry about doing drugs or
anything else we're not gonna put any of
those restrictions on you can come and
go as you like
you know so so there is something that
see this is not me but a scholar i had a
long conversation with called the
the homeless industrial complex once
there's money
in bidding and getting
a homeless shelters for big developers
you better be careful
all right we talked about new york city
yeah we talked about afghanistan
seems like the segway to where we're at
right now in california
what do you make about what's going on
with this state we we both we talked
about it about a month ago on your show
yeah i was strongly considering leaving
like i was looking at real estate i
had a whole bunch of people begging me
to come to dallas i would have had a
pretty sweet operation over there yeah
my feeling right now is i want to stay
and fight here i love i love socal
i love you know i love the weather of
course and all that but like i've built
a good life here we've got
friends i like it here it's a freaking
mess absolute mess i think you're in a
bit of a similar
situation i am and i i didn't think
about staying and fighting until i spoke
to you
and i haven't stopped thinking about
that and i think you're right
um i i was just in austin looking at
property
and boy does that oh i know we probably
i told you we're probably looking at the
same houses i'm on truly like man what i
can get in austin
the amount of money i can save it's
cheaper to live it's that you know i
don't pay that 13
tax or whatever it is or 18 um so yeah i
could save a lot of money
and um what's happening in california it
seems is businesses are leaving for just
that reason
because it's very expensive to do
business here what california
has going for it is a very diversified
economy and amazing weather
and it's just a huge important state for
a lot of reasons but california was the
state that worked
and we have a democratic supermajority
and uh if you look at local politics
it's it's just
anytime you have a super majority of any
group i don't care if it's republican or
democrat i don't think that's good for
democracy
um your vote if you are someone who
leans even a little bit right doesn't
count
save it stay home we don't care and you
aren't getting elected to local office
you're not getting elected to to
government office
you're not unless you are pro big union
across the board
good luck good luck otherwise and i'm a
member of a union i'm in sag
so i i understand the value of unions
but
it's expensive to do business and unless
you can
push back a little bit or come up with a
compromise i don't
i don't i'm not bullish on california
and that ain't me i've talked to some
very smart people who are
economic animals and all of them
agree and all of them are looking to get
out because
it's too expensive why why i live in
on skid row basically i'm in venice i've
been in venice for 25 years i love it
but i don't recognize my town anymore as
much
and you know it's gotten really bad over
there right it's not just gotten very
bad it's become profitable
because developers now can get these
government contracts i mean
i can build you i can build you a bunch
of apartments for 200 million dollars on
prime real estate on a parking lot
and on the beach if you'd like i'd be
happy to do that and we can just have
we can create a homeless uh apartments
peop for people who are homeless and
don't worry about doing drugs or
anything
else we're not gonna put any of those
restrictions on you can come and go as
you like
you know so so there is something that
see this is not me but a scholar i had a
long conversation with called the
the homeless industrial complex once
there's money
in bidding and getting
uh homeless shelters for big developers
you better be careful so these people
need to be put in treatment
the majority of the people on the street
it's not a housing problem
it's not a housing problem it's not a
housing problem it is
a mental health and addiction problem
and until we get serious about that
uh we're we're going to be in big
trouble is it weird to you watching it
spread in different areas so venice
always had a certain amount of that
now it's definitely more but like
hollywood which also always had a
certain amount
it's like kind of taking over hollywood
if you just go to straight up
especially now where there aren't as
many other people on the streets now it
just seems like all there
are kind of like transient people and
homeless and tents
and well you you and as that inches
closer to west hollywood now it'll lynch
closer to beverly hills and that that
then is oh my gosh that meant it
gets pushed yeah well you know they have
their own police force but yeah prop 47
and you can't it's not criminalized
they're all
these i voted for 47 because the way it
was phrased
and it had it had the again on the
ballot
as i'm voting i went well this makes
sense i don't want kids to be in a
revolving door of crime
and and police chiefs back it and did
you read the whole thing
i didn't that's it i didn't have time
remiss but that's how they get you in
this state i think more than any other
during the last election there was this
one thing on the ballot
about um you know do you want it it was
something like this do you want to put
500 million dollar
into education for you know blah blah
blah blah and then there's
essay just a giant crazy essay on the
whole thing and i skipped all the way to
the bottom and on the bottom it says
this can only be
repealed or reversed by popular vote
but nobody ever says okay now we'll take
the money from the kids
but that's government 101. that's right
you sell it exactly the packaging thing
you're talking about
away nobody reads the fine print and
then you throw it back on the people to
be like oh you'll have to take care of
this
deal with this there's always blowback
there's always a ripple effect
no matter what the intentions are you
know we've spent something like three
trillion dollars
on programs for the poor how's that
going
how's it going you know it it it it's
very difficult
i i i think at the end of the day it's
not about right or left you've got to
ask yourself do you really think that a
bloated bureaucracy called the federal
government
is the first line of defense is that the
best way to solve these problems
is it i don't i don't i don't think so
is government going to keep
families intact is it government
official or a bureaucrat who
studies family law or whatever going to
keep your family intact
are they going to are they going to get
you to take care of your kids
are they going to get you the skills
that you need in the 21st century the
ever-changing 21st century
uh it's a question yeah maybe the answer
is yes in some cases
but i don't know if that's always the
question the answer and you've got to
ask those questions
the problem we run into is we go well
i'm a republican i'm a democrat i'm left
i'm right
this no hold on hold on let's let's go
into
what percentage of your money do you
want to give the government every
year every day i i pay something like 52
in taxes so half my day half my year
is working for someone else half my day
half my year
is working for someone else so how much
more do you want from me
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about comedy
instead of the non-stop yelling you get
everywhere else check out our comedy
playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell